-You know
that we love dogs here
and we especially love
talented dogs
and we found some very talented
dogs that we want you to meet.
It's time for "What's Up Dog
Sports Edition"
♪ What's Up Dog? ♪
-Sports Edition!
-Welcome to "What's Up Dog?
Sports Edition."
Let's meet our first dog
and find out what sport
they're playing.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hi. Nice to see you.
What is your name?
-Yannick Devost.
-Hey, Yannick.
Who'd you bring with us today?
-Maggie.
-Hi, Maggie!
-[ Whimpering ]
-What kind of dog is Maggie?
-A German shepherd.
-A German shepherd. Maggie.
What sport does Maggie
play here?
I'm assuming hockey?
-Yep, hockey.
She's a real life hockey goalie.
-She's a hockey goalie.
Alright. She's excited now.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, look, she's getting ready.
Now, what is the trick,
she just blocks all the shots?
-No. So, she only focuses
on the puck.
I'll try to distract her
by shooting all the balls.
She'll ignore them, and she'll
only focus on the puck.
-I got to see this.
Alright, Maggie,
you're in the net.
You're ready to go.
Roots [indistinct]
-Can you hold on to that for me?
-Sure, of course.
-Goalie.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ohhs ]
[ Awws ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-What?!
Wow! Wow! Wow! Wow! Wow!
That was awesome!
Maggie!
Can we see that in slow-motion?
That's great.
Oh, my gosh!
Look at that. Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
Ow! Chomps!
Good job!
Great job, buddy.
Thank you so much.
You can head over there.
-Thank you.
-Yannick, tank you very much
for being here.
Go on, Maggie.
Thank you very much.
Alright,
let's meet our next dog
and find out what sport
they are playing.
Come on over, guys.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-How are you, Jim?
-Pleasure.
-I'm Dave.
-Jimmy. Hey, Dave.
-I'm Dan.
-Hey, Dan.
Nice to meet you guys.
And who's this?
-This is Pepper.
-[ Baby voice ] Hi, Pepper!
Nice to see you.
Pepper. Now, Pepper --
what kind of dog is Pepper?
She's an Australian cattle dog.
-An Australian cattle dog.
She's very excited.
-Oh, she's fired up,
ready to go.
-You're holding
two sports things,
so I don't know
what sport she plays.
-Kind of a Wiffle
hockey baseball.
-Wickey --
Wiffle hockey baseball.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-That's what Pepper enjoys?
-That's what she's into.
-Yeah.
And how does this work?
-Well, she holds the bat,
I hit the ball to her
with the hockey stick,
and she hits it.
[ Laughter ]
-Hopefully.
Hopefully.
-What do you mean, hopefully?
It's going to work.
This'll be great. Alright.
What can I do to help, anything?
Just get out of the way?
-Duck.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, yeah.
Good man. Good man.
Alright, cool. Perfect.
You want to just give her
the bat...
-Here we go.
-...and go for it?
[ Drumroll ]
Okay.
-Ready?
[ Audience murmuring ]
Alright.
Get in your spot right here.
Stay there.
Stay.
[ Playing whimsical
suspenseful tune ]
♪♪
Got to trash talk sometimes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You can't hit.
You're a dog.
[ Laughter ]
Ready?
-Oh.
-Strike one!
[ Laughter ]
Come on, Pepper!
You got this one!
-Come on, Pepper!
-I think she believed me --
she couldn't hit.
She's a dog.
Ready?
-Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's pretty good.
[ Rimshot ]
I'll take that.
Can we see that in slow-motion?
I like that.
It was a swing.
She swung at it.
Look at -- what?
Yes! Alright, good.
I'll take that.
Thank you very much
for being here.
I appreciate it.
Pepper, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Pepper.
Take care.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, Pepper. Take care.
Alright,
let's meet our last dog.
Come on over here.
What's your name?
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Hey.
-[ Laughs ]
Wow. Cool.
The dog just skateboarded in.
That was awesome.
Was that the trick?
-Part of it.
-Yeah, that was amazing.
Hi. Jimmy.
-Hi. Chrissy.
-Hi, Chrissy. Hi. Jimmy.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-This is Kevin.
-[ Laughing ]
-Good job.
-That's awesome.
[ Awws ]
Oh, wow!
What a beautiful little --
What?
What kind of dog?
-He's a. border collie.
-He's a border collie.
-What is his name again?
-Kevin Bacon.
[ Laughter ]
-Kev--
There you go.
I'm a big fan, Kevin.
-Come say hi.
-Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Good job, bud.
-What does Kevin Bacon do?
-So, he's a huge helper
around the house,
but today he's going to get you
a beer from the fridge.
You can chug it, if you'd like.
[ Laughter ]
And then he's going to take it
to the trash can for you.
-Oh, and recycle.
Thank you so much, Kevin Bacon.
Kevin Bacon, this is fantastic.
What do I have to do here?
-Make sure you pick up the can
when he brings it to you.
-Sure.
-Pretty simple.
-Yeah, no problem.
-Alright. Can you maybe open?
Look. Open.
Good. Go take.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Good. Bring it.
Give it to him.
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you, Kevin.
-Hey, buddy.
-And then I drink it?
-If you want to.
-Alright.
-There you go.
-Kevin, I just drank it.
I'm done with this beer.
-Hey, trash can.
Please put it in.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah!
That's the best!
Kevin Bacon! Come on, bud. Oh!
-Yeah!
-That's the best!
-Good job.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Great job, Kevin Bacon.
Great job to all of our dogs.
If you have a dog
with a fun talent, go to...
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Molly Shannon, everybody.
Wow!
[ Cheering and applause ]
What an amazing --
You are [indistinct].
♪♪